how did it go writing the code to save
the profile in the datastore let's take
a quick look at the code here I am and
the save profile method and we'll scroll
down to where we create the profile and
save it so we already had this line of
code to create the profile and then
saving it in the entity was this simple
or fee dot saved or entity profile dot
now okay now let's see what properties
show up in the datastore admin so here
we are in the datastore viewer looking
at the profile entity for my profile
lemon cake see here we have the display
name and the other properties that we
see are the main email and the t-shirt
size the property that's missing is user
ID the user ID was specified as the ID
for the entity and it's used in the
entity key the ID field isn't saved as a
separate property on the entity okay
let's go back and hear what Magnus has
to say next